yeah that is the reaction of champion
Magnus
Coulson well how did this happen what
exactly he
missed let's find out in the 12th round
of the 2023 World Blitz Championship Ian
choose the move C5 in this position
which is a mistake however Magnus
quickly dropped his Bishop back on
E7 the Tactical point is black can
actually take this pawn and get a
healthy Pawn
Advantage how well let's see it
if white captures the bishop now then
black can initiate Queen trade and at
the end get the piece back with Rook
takes E2 and you can simply see that in
the final position black emerges with a
pawn Advantage especially at that level
and for Magnus this can be a huge Factor
later on the game fizzled out as a draw
and after the game when Magnus was
discussing with Ian his opponent pointed
out the mistake he made and as soon as
Coulson realized it he was shocked and
disgusted as he missed a big time
opportunity